S
ACROSS AMERICA.
>> WE HOPE YOU WILL JOIN US ON
THIS MISSION.
>> Tucker: A MISSION OF
EQUITY.
ARE YOU GOING TO JOIN THE
MISSION OF EQUITY?
CAN YOU DEFINE IT?
WE KNOW WHAT THAT MISSION LOOKS
LIKE, HE WAS A COMMANDER IN THE
SPACE FORCE, FIRED FOR SPEAKING
OUT AGAINST THE OPEN POLITICAL
INDOCTRINATION HE SAW THERE.
HE'S THE AUTHOR OF THE BOOK --
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO, NASA YOU WOULD THINK WOULD
BE THE ONE BRANCH AGENCY THAT
WOULD BE IMMUNE FROM THE EQUITY
MISSION.
THAT YOU SERVED IN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT FOR A LONG TIME, WERE
YOU UNDER THE IMPRESSION THAT
NASA HAD A PROBLEM WITH
DISCRIMINATION IN YEARS PAST?
>> I DON'T KNOW, TOOK IT TO
THINGS FIRST OFF FOR HAVING ME
ON YOUR SHOW.
AS ALWAYS, I DON'T SPEAK FOR THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT, BUT I SPEAK
FOR MYSELF.
I DON'T THINK THAT ANY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS AT THIS POINT ARE
IMMUNE FROM THIS IDEA THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE PURSUING EQUITY.
CLEARLY, THESE ARE HOT TOPICS.
DID THE TALKING POINT OF THE
DAY -- IN FACT, I DO WANT TO
DEFINE IT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I KNOW THE DEFINITION OF EQUITY.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EQUITY AND
EQUALITY.
ONE OF THEM IS GOOD, AND THE
IDEAL APPEARED TO BE THERE GOOD.
WE TEND TO CONFUSE THE EQUALITY
OF OPPORTUNITY, AND IDEAL, PART
OF PHILOSOPHIES WITH EQUITY.
IT'S A NEW TERM, ITS USE
WITTINGLY, WHICH ESSENTIALLY
MEANS AND FORCED OUT COLUMNS OR
ENFORCED ANY QUALITY.
BASED OUT OF WHAT I'VE SEEN IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE IS
PERMEATING INSTITUTIONS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, AND ESSENTIALLY
POTENTIALLY ILLEGALLY
DISCRIMINATORY POLICY.
EQUITY IS NOT GOOD AS IT IS
DEFINED, BUT IT SOUNDS GOOD,
THAT'S WHY WE USE THE WORD.
NASA HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN -- I
THINK -- A SYMBOL OF INCLUSION
AND EQUAL OPPORTUNITY.
NASA IS THE KIND OF ORGANIZATION
THAT PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT, AND
UNDERSTANDS THAT REGARDLESS OF
YOUR BACKGROUND, YOU ARE ABLE TO
SHOW UP HERE JUST LIKE IN THE
DEFENSE DEPARTMENT, AND RISE UP
BASED ON YOUR MARRIAGE, AND HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A NAME
FOR YOURSELF, TO RISE TO
LEADERSHIP, AND TO DO IMPORTANT
THINGS FOR THE COUNTRY.
BECAUSE THERE'S A UNIFYING
MISSION THAT THESE INSTITUTIONS
BELIEVE IN, WHETHER IT'S SPACE
EXPLORATION IN THE CASE OF NASA
OR DEFENDING OUR COUNTRY AND OUR
ALLIES FROM SERIOUS THOUGHTS
THAT I HAVE IN THE WORLD.
PEOPLE IN UNIFORM, FOR EXAMPLE,
RALLY AROUND THAT MISSION, AND
HAVE HISTORICALLY NOT BEEN
CAUGHT UP IN THE KIND OF
IDENTITY POLITICKING THAT YOU'RE
TALKING BOUT THAT I AM HEARING
IN YOUR MONOLOGUE.
I WILL MAKE ONE POINT TO SAY
THAT I THINK ARE SENIOR LEADERS
AND OUR NATIONAL LEADERS NEED TO
THINK VERY CAREFULLY ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO
INJECT TRIBALISM INTO OUR LONG
TRUSTED INSTITUTIONS IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT TYPICALLY HAVE NOT
BEEN AFFECTED WITH TRIBAL
THINKING, WITH ALL OF THAT
ENTAILS.
DO WE REALLY WANT TO WALK THE
ROAD THAT WILL CAUSE US TO
ABANDON MARTIN LUTHER KING JR.'S
DREAM OF HAVING A COLORLESS
SOCIETY WHERE, IN FACT, WE ARE
STARTING ONCE AGAIN TO JUDGE
PEOPLE BY THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN.
IMPUGNING GUILT TO OTHER GROUPS
OF PEOPLE BASED ON THEIR GROUP
IDENTITY, NOT BECAUSE OF
ANYTHING THEY'VE EVER DONE
NECESSARILY THEMSELVES, BUT
BASED ON WHO THEY ARE
ACCIDENTALLY, EVEN.
THAT'S A GOOD DEFINITION OF
RACISM.
WE DON'T IMPUGNING GUILT TO
PEOPLE BASED ON THE COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN.
>> Tucker: AND WE NEVER
SHOWED.
I ALWAYS IMAGINED THE MILITARY
IS THE SHINING BEACON OF WHAT
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY SHOULD
BE BECAUSE IT WAS A COLOR-BLIND
MERITOCRACY.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL --
>> THE MILITARY IS GREAT AT
THAT.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
UPSET ABOUT WHAT THEY ARE
HEARING.
>> Tucker: AND THEY HAV